all right ashley thank you for that  muslim worshipers marked the end of the  first day of ramadan with prayers and a  meal at masjid ibrahim in north las  vegas this is the first time in two  years the mosque is celebrating in  person due to the pandemic ramadan is  the holiest month of the islamic year  when muslims are expected to fast from  dawn to dusk it's all in an effort to  renew their focus on spiritual matters  rather than material things having the  celebration back in person with no  restrictions has made this year's  ramadan even more special  it's important spiritually more so than  anything else it's simple it's important  spiritually for a community to have a a  place of safety so to speak  to be able to gather in peace to worship  god and to enjoy fellowship with each  other  ramadan continues throughout the month  and will end on may 1st